[Music]
the following trailer is rated s for
super spoilers from Zack Snyder the
visionary director behind legend of the
guardians the owls of ga'hoole comes the
world's most hopeful superhero in his
inevitable darkbootie Christopher Nolan
update because God forbid a Superman
movie be any damn fun for anybody Man of
Steel prepare for a mopey
violent reboot guaranteed to depress
adults and frighten small children where
one of America's greatest icons Superman
is played by this English man with the
acting range of a crumpet who are you I
am your father come that's funny
but my god what a beefcake he's the hero
who stood for truth justice and the
American Way
but this time stands for destroying
American property twelve million dollar
piece of hardware it was the Canadian
Arctic
this guy's livelihood Bruce Wayne
satellite downtown Smallville and like
half of Metropolis
it's a bird it's a plane it's coming
right for us everybody run journey to
Superman's birthplace of Pandora Krypton
an alien planet full of avatar Birds
matrix babies sepia tone way too many
subplots Krypton's core is collapsing I
know you stole the Codex and ships
shaped like Wang's meet General Zod a
Kryptonian out to destroy humanity with
the power of dub staff
[Music]
in order to defeat Zod Superman must
decide which of his to Robinhood dad's
to listen to space dad says show off
your powers to inspire humanity you
could be the bridge between two peoples
farm dad says hide your powers and let
innocent people die I supposed to do
that I'm dying
maybe watch Superman honor them both as
he shows off his powers and let innocent
people die
meet Lois Lane a Pulitzer prize-winning
reporter I'm a Pulitzer prize-winning
reporter that's what I just said she's a
superhero in her own right with the
powers of staying alive in sub-freezing
temperatures scaling ice mountains
seducing hot space dudes and showing up
wherever the plot need her to be this
woman to accompany me come on there's no
reason she should be on that military
plane Hey that's what she said when Lois
uses her nikon camera to photograph this
budweiser creaking alien she'll discover
the truth from his friend at the aiya
but when Zod since her a message on this
nokia phone it's up to Superman to take
him on with this u-haul truck through
this 7-eleven back to the IR and inside
this Sears
so if you love the Christopher Reeve era
Superman movies but which they made them
less offal killed countless civilians
visualized our worst fears of urban
terrorism and that Superman overcome his
first villain by murdering it with his
bare hands
DC has made the reboot for you psycho
[Applause]
yikes
story specific Zod April O'Neil
ghost dead fallout box art Kevin Costco
Perry black Superman pooping and those
pin art desk boy things you know with
Spencer's gifts the one used to press
your face against guys no one about
right Man of Steel can't believe I'm now
actually rooting for Ben Affleck to kick
this guy's ass thanks for watching I am
going to steal the Declaration of
Independence the church store called and
they ran out of you spoon the Fox says
what I say it says I am vengeance I am
the knight I am Batman hey screen
junkies for more awesome stuff click
here to subscribe